the game cinematics have been amazing
for us because it's really taught us to
craft the storytelling and to be
comfortable with lots of different
styles that shot's such a flex like dang
this shot we assembled in an hour an
hour because that's all we had and I was
like what are we gonna do
so you guys have the sickest lightsaber
fights you guys should have made that
Halo show
but now I gotta say it again but for
Star Wars
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video stick around so you can find out
how to get three months free
next artist react and today we have a
very special episode because in the past
how we wanted to talk about game
cinematics but today we finally have the
chance because our guest today is Jerome
Don Jean so Jerome welcome could you
please tell us a little bit about
yourself and like the work you do yeah
well I've been uh I've been working at
blur studio for 20 years I was the head
of CG at blur 304 for about four five
years and then and then lately I've been
kind of dedicating my time to this show
on Netflix called The Love dust and
robot and my role is to just make sure
that all the all the companies that
we're working with make sure that
everything goes smoothly and that
everything looks good you give us a list
of iconic historic defining cinematics
animations
and I think we should just jump in and
start knocking it down let's do it all
right time to go on a journey
[Music]
X-Men Origins
oh wow I'm checking out some Wolverine
oh wow oh wait this isn't the movie
oh that was so confusing
from the movie so did I I thought this
was a shot from the movie right here
wait is it no
uh so this this you know like we've
we've worked on a lot of um we worked on
a lot of projects like that where like a
game is tied to the release of a movie
and they're expecting like kind of
cutscenes that will look exactly like
the movie but we only have like you know
a fraction of the budget Kevin the
supervisor was all into like doing this
like for real scenes and that first shot
in particular like I I still it for you
guys uh because but and at the time like
I think this this one was like 2007 2008
uh some of that so what was the what was
the big move here that let you guys
start approaching like photorealism you
know like every new generation of
renderer it brings new technology and
then it takes a while before we're so
comfortable with it that we can just
push it to like the limit and this one
was one of the last ones where we were
using mantore at the at the time and
that was the max you could do with
mental rate but you know it's like the
all the generations in gaming you know
like each new like Xbox or Playstation
when the new Xbox or Playstation comes
out like the games that are released
they don't quite take advantage of the
technology yet like it takes like a few
years before the developers are so
comfortable about that they can push it
too and it's usually just right before a
new generation of consoles gets out that
you get those fullest of what that
console can do that's like the Shadows
of the Colossus drops for your PS2 where
it's like oh you can do this
just took about 10 years to figure it
out but
foreign
this one was one of those like 10
fashion projects because they're
superheroes like Tim would be like okay
we're gonna do this thing in three
minutes and then it turns into like you
know five minutes and then instead of 30
shots an hour you got like 90 shots so
I'd be like no no we gotta we gotta
stick to 30 shots but like you look at
every shot it's like five shots combined
yeah camera turns around and then here's
like an entire new group of guys
okay
this was like the money shot like the
big the big explosion the effect
supervisor Brandon like to spend a ton
of time on it and it's beautiful funny
story so like there's a shot later of
the aftermath this shot we used to
handled in an hour an hour because
that's all we had and I was like what
are we gonna do and so we just we
grabbed like all the smoke cards we
could find whether it was like online or
in our library we rendered it and then
we just like animated like a little bit
of like displacement
um infusion and look at that yeah that's
amazing yeah the shot looks incredible
an hour but man that was a stressful
hour
[Laughter]
this one was the the first project where
we used v-ray and that was that one
allowed us to do bigger things and it
was just more advanced in terms of the
ray tracing like we weren't we didn't
have to cheat like stuff as much we
started to be able to like render like
atmospheric smoke and stuff like you
know it started to look a little bit
more realistic but you know it was the
first project with it so there's still
there's still things that were not quite
mastering you know I see like in the
hair in particular the hair it would it
would render the hair but it would not
motion blur
so we had to render the hair and
something else we're still using virado
because it's kept up with technology and
like all those uh all these like
rendering techniques and it's a much
different renderer now than it was at
the time but at the time it was already
like allowing us to do things that we
couldn't do before
stay behind me
so you guys have some of the sickest
lightsaber fights
yeah I was about to say earlier man you
out you guys should have made that Halo
show
but now I gotta say it again but for
Star Wars we've done we've done a lot of
storage cinematics uh over the years I
think this scene is probably like the
culmination of it I love everything
about it and and I couldn't talk about
it because I didn't work on it like but
I remember when that one was being made
we were all like every day just like
looking on the on the server to just see
like what the like the latest renders
were because
because it's just so great like they did
like an entire shoot one night at blur
like on a parking lot but they had like
this like a whole system uh to uh shoot
like like rain cars so all you know it's
like all about these like little details
that just add to like the realism but
the lighting the rain the choreography
yeah it's just like I don't know that's
that's one of my favorites
I loved like the spotlight behind them
like we're just lighting right
everything else around yep
just the Silhouettes against the fog and
the smoke like and and everything is
moving and there's nothing that you know
like the stuff from 20 years ago where
you just like pause and you look in the
corner you're like that smoke I don't
know
the lightsabers are kind of an
interesting like technological like
thing too where you can kind of see the
advances in the rendering
um the first cinematics that we did
would have to like put like Point lights
you know and then just animate like that
and it never looked like as good as like
by now you know v-ray can render like
like a nice little lightsaber and the
motion blur is just right and the
reflections are great but yeah the
lighting on her like just the
reflections of that lightsaber like that
sequence I've always loved it because
there's not much yeah but it's a there's
a suggestion of of a lot of details
there's all those like little lens
things you know that that just kind of
make it look filmic well the the thing
is like when the the first Old Republic
ones came out like the rendering was
excellent but it was like the first time
since you know the prequels that had
seen like that awesome level of like
lightsaber choreography and it was so it
was just this really really cool
combination personally when you were
talking about what's the blur look
earlier I feel like that was it for me
it's like all right and actually like
really well-crafted lightsaber battle
the game cinematics have been I've been
amazing for us because it's really
taught us the craft of Storytelling and
to be comfortable with lots of different
styles and that's always something that
we've loved that blur like to be uh to
be comfortable with all those different
styles like we've never wanted to be
pigeonholed into like one one particular
style but the game cinematics we have
fantastic clients that ask us to tell a
little story with uh with a game
cinematic and that's really how the
studio and all our directors to just
kind of get better at it so that now
loved us and robots is really like the
combination of all those years doing
dancing matter hey if you like the show
and you're not
you're not well consider subscribing
it's that easy
so this this one the first time we saw
it we're like oh this is gonna be this
is gonna be something and this cinematic
to this day is still one of my favorite
uh and it was done by digik in Hungary
huh that was their first like big
project and then they've put out like a
ton of uh projects and I've always been
grateful for these guys because they've
really kept us on our toes and trying to
kind of like catch up a little bit
because they were coming for more the
VFX side of things and so they had some
techniques and some you know so they
were using some stuff that we were not
really used to uh to using and you could
tell like there was there was just
something extra about that cinematics
some of the things that really stand out
to me like feels like the you have a big
softbox for the sky and everything has a
like soft top-down Lighting in the 90s
at least in the very early 2000s
lighting is kind of like a here's a
point and light comes out from that
point and you know maybe you can put
multiple points and kind of make it look
like it's soft or you can start getting
into like you know yeah you can kind of
do soft Shadows Now by blurring them but
like to have it feel like everything was
lit by Roger deacons he's like such a
level up from just like some extra like
CG lights now they're getting that like
that diffused foggy Bloom look like
that's something that's kind of hard to
achieve because if you're not like going
to actually simulate a ton of fog for
every shot here which they're probably
not you know you don't want to do that
generally it's like it's really render
intensive if you're gonna have like
rendered fog so it's it is instantly
impressive just because of that like
setting
you have really nice motion blur and the
motion blur looks great and the
highlights like get blurred correctly
and you have curved motion blur and then
you have like good camera Shake where
it's got that organic feel to it yeah
they were using they were using stuff
that we weren't that we didn't have like
there was there was something I remember
something about the motion blur and we
were pausing on those frames and we you
could see like the protocols had this
like curvy motion blur which at the time
we didn't have because because Max at
the time could only calculate the
translation between from point A to
point B so all our particles like if you
pause on the frame like you see it's
just a straight line and and it but damn
it looked like this
and uh and we're like wow when we
started love dancing robots and we were
like what if we put out you know a show
with with cinematic like you know like
little short stories done by by the best
of the best for like all right it's
called
we got to call them and work with them
and we did on the first season of uh
they did the secret War I love these
guys like they're they're so inspiring
[Music]
a new kid showed up oh yes there is a
new kid on the Block and they were they
were in Paris their um that studio is
called Unit so they're the studio who
did beyond the killer Rift and uh snow
in the desert in um in love desert
robots and they've been getting better
and better with each project
and like the shirt cloth animation on
top of like all the deforming pig flesh
look what the pig flesh though still
even still it's just like the pig flesh
you talk about the skin the eyes blah
blah but it's like when it's a character
you have to look at it like you're gonna
look at the character who's speaking and
if like your skin looks weird it's just
like constantly distracting you but this
one is just like you're just instantly
like sucked into it because it's just at
this level of detail and this the
shininess it's like so I don't know it's
very visceral look at the Reflections in
the eye like yeah you know by now like
that's something that we can do like
with relatives is so unit is is using
3ds Max also so it's really great to
have like a competitor that's using the
same tools that you are because then you
got no excuse for uh not putting up you
know just a project
just as Yama described it
true freedom but that's such a flex
check out my eye modeling dang these are
like these are usually the shots for
like the studios compete you know it's
like do do an eye shot like that like
now like we dare you and then you know
when we sent them the the story of
beyond the killer Rift they were like
but don't you have something with like
more effects because they were doing
like a lot of a lot of stuff with like a
lot of effects a lot of explosions and
and Beyond the killer riff only had like
it's like this kind of intimate like
piece with just like a few characters
with like lots of emotions and they're
like well we've never really done that
but we were like
we think you'd be good at it
and then um they're amazingly smart
people and they've figured it out that
and now like some of their official
animations just the best in the best in
business you know
so this one was done by platish there in
uh in Poland and you know it's another
one of those companies that just kind of
came out as a competitors this one when
he came out we were like how the hell
are they doing this I have no idea like
how and still to this day I still don't
understand how they're doing it but you
know it's one of the cinemas that I
always they always stuck with us and and
and we always kind of went back to it
because it got such like a unique style
but I don't love this in robots they did
the fish night in the first season in a
bit of a similar style I've seen so many
like cell shaded renders so to speak
they would they everyone's trying to
figure out how to get around drawing 2D
animations by hand frame by frame and
cell shading was basically like the
answer to that but like it's always it
was really weird looking for even a lot
of like major like shows that had used
it animes and then when I saw this one I
was like wow this is like at that level
and even more because it's so stylized
it's like it's not just like a 2d
cartoon it's like using that as
inspiration but then going for further
you're not just trying to replicate a 2d
animation but you're getting this nice
in between using like both techniques
yeah you still feel the volume but but
they have these like 2D edges it's
beautiful it's like the Spiderman the
spider-verse you know yeah yeah then
it's just then you get lines to rig and
get like a lot of stuff to do there's
just as much work as drawing it right
exactly it's also just worth mentioning
like the only way you're getting
animation like this is when somebody
just does a crazy short because they're
passionate or it's a video game
cinematic no one's making movies with
this kind of 3D animation like it's
Pixar DreamWorks and that's it you don't
get to see this kind of stuff unless
some Renegade companies like screw it
we're gonna do it yeah they're all
companies of storytellers and it's
really important because like all those
projects have helped like all our
companies to just become better at
telling stories and and that's what's
going to resonate like you know later oh
hey oh it's time it's time to leave a
comment for your favorite game
cinematics let us know in the comments
below hey guys how is happy Saturday I'm
Jordan and I'm here to talk to you about
today's sponsor expressvpn I remember a
day back in 2021 I was sitting there
watching my favorite show the office and
then all of a sudden it's not there
anymore
it was like the world went dark but ever
since then I've still been watching the
office on Netflix because I just had to
use expressvpn to tell them that I'm in
Canada and then boom I was able to watch
Michael Scott say that's what she said
their servers and 94 countries so that
means you can change your location to
nearly any country in the world and
watch whatever you want it's that simple
expressvpn has incredible fast speeds
there's never any buffering so you can
stream HD quality no problem
expressvpn also protects your data it's
physically impossible for any of
expressvpns VPN servers to store logs of
any customers that must be why it's
rated the top VPN provider rated number
one by CNET The Verge Mashable tech
radar and more if you never want to feel
the way I did back in 2021 go to
expressvpn.com Corridor crew or click
the link in the description below and
you can get three months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot com slash Corridor crew to get three
months free it's that easy that's what
she said okay okay I'm gonna go tell
expressvpn that I'm in Canada so I can
keep watching the office enjoy the rest
of the show
so you're looking at your history of
blur studio and all the time you've been
there not counting love death and robots
what was your favorite IP to work with
you know just re-watching them like like
that has been has been interesting what
I love about blur even more than the
work is the people that I've worked with
and and the collaboration and just the
way we've you know we've we've taken
that studio from 30 people to to what it
is now you know it's a lot of late
nights but it's also like a lot of
passion and working with like I'm sure
you guys are very well aware of that you
know the whole crew it's uh it's a human
Adventure more than just you know more
than the results like that are on on
YouTube and I gotta say I'm I'm proud of
the studio when I when I look at all
that that stuff because it's um we
covered a lot of grounds and we had a
lot of fun doing it man this is really
cool it's such a neat trip down both
Memory Lane but also just like game
Cinema history yeah and the experiences
that you shared with us the observations
the
you know the thoughts that you've had
it's been invaluable and super cool and
thank you for for joining us and sharing
all that and thank you guys for uh for
having me like it's it's been great it's
been great to like you know talk about
all this like just see uh just see it
all um all again and
um I hope um I hope I cast a little bit
of light on oh certainly the history of
some of it we'll have to do this again
sometime yeah
cool all right everybody thank you so
much for watching we'll see you in the
next one